Okay. The ranking order for correlation of these graphs,
would be graph number three is the strongest correlation. Graph
number one is the next strongest correlation. Graph number four
has the next strongest correlation And the second graph has
the weakest correlation. Now think about this with me for
just a second. Think about why this is. What we're
going to do is measure a couple of points in
our graph. Take a look at our strongest correlating graph.
You see if we go over to any given point,
we come down at about the same place. On the
horizontal axis, on the x axis. The y axis and
the x axis values are roughly the same for each point.
They're pretty close together. They're a match. And now notice
that in our weakest correlated graph, that if we go to
any given point, wow, we're kind of all over the
place, right? I mean, we have a relatively high height for
twin two here, but that point goes down to a
relatively low height for twin one. So that wasn't a
very high match. We do the same thing here. We
had a lower height for twin two, and a really high
height for twin one at that point. So these are
not correlating very well, and this is the graphical representation
of that. If you have any trouble, you should definitely
check out the Udacity course on statistics, co-taught by Katie Kormanik.
And also go to the discussion forums for this video and
see if you can get some advice or help from your classmates.